je bouge beaucoup rond fait pas la
sourde oreille avec moi permettez vite
allô
allô attends je rentre oui
tu m'entends mieux là
et là
là tu m'entends mieux
est-ce que tu m'entends mieux
non je comprends rien ces sacs à des
heures indues
alors
allô allô
oui pas le plus fort je n'entends pas je
n'entends pas attendez
je vois bien qu'il ya des clients alors
attends attends voyez pas de téléphone
mais je sais de façon gêne c'est dingue
ça c'est vous qui êtes dos roger moore
oui
bah ouais mais je vois bien qu'à des
candidats et moi je fais quoi ce tricot
ouais j'entends pas j'entends par là
j'entends parler
calmez vous je suis très calme
pour
et j'entends rien déjà tous assez
compliqué comme ça
je suis à côté d'une bonne là et ça
grésille un peu
ouais lever le bras voir parce que ça
grésille
alors ouais alors oui ça va
oui m et parlait pas en même temps
voyait en train de téléphoner quand même
sur toile vous venez à hurler derrière
de qui moi non mais oh no
way
ouais alors alors oui tu m'entends non
ça ça grésille un peu
beaucoup ouais
bon ben je te laisse ciao ciao
et marche bien le vôtre
c'est quoi cette caméra
non
[Musique]